what's going on guys this is rob and as
much as i love beyond omega level we
need a new series leave some comments
down in the comment section and let me
know of a new series that we should
create but what's going on and we are
back again with another edition of
beyond omega level where we break down
the most powerful characters and comics
and today we're focusing on a character
who is as absurdly powerful as he is
stupid looking i mean seriously this has
got to be one of the most poorly
designed characters that we've ever
covered in this series but regardless
today we're covering zom who's just well
you guys will realize how powerful he is
so zom was created by stan lee and marie
severan and first appeared in strange
tales number 156 in 1967 and at that
time strange tales was the series where
you would find the adventures of doctor
strange and zom is closely tied to one
of strange's most iconic villains a guy
named dormammu now since we don't know
any details about zom's origin instead
we'll be talking about his introduction
into the marvel universe which comes
about as a result of a battle between
doctor strange and dormammu's sister
umar so umar had basically returned from
being banished to another dimension by
her brother dormammu a few issues before
zom showed up and she says the reason
dormammu banished her in the first place
was that he was jealous that she was
more powerful than he was so if we took
umar at her word we can conclude that
she is herself beyond an omega level
threat but because dormammu definitely
is and she claims that she's more
powerful it makes sense so she may warn
her own video in this series later on if
you guys really want to see that then
let me know but regardless umar returns
and terrorizes doctor strange for a
handful of issues and as powerful as he
is and keep in mind that doctor strange
used to be a lot more powerful in the
comics than he is now he along with his
mentor the ancient one are unable to
defeat her so they get desperate for
anything that will allow them to win and
the ancient one teleports strange to a
world beyond all worlds and tells them
that they have no chance against umar on
their own and suddenly a vase appears
the strange refers to as the legendary
m4 now the ancient one tells strange
that within the amphora is an entity
called zom and he's basically imprisoned
there and at first strange is shocked
because he thought zomb was simply a
myth but the ancient one assures him
that zom is real and has been imprisoned
for ages by eternity himself now while
zom was imprisoned by eternity what was
this guy doing you guys know what's
coming i can tell you exactly what it
was zom was doing while he was locked
away in this vase he was playing heroes
of lithus or technically bloodline
heroes of lithus is what is referred to
and i gotta tell you guys one i've been
looking for a new mobile game to play
and two i'm glad these guys hit me up
because this game has one of the most
unique features of any mobile game that
i've ever played so at the outset this
game has what you've come to expect from
mobile games which is to say that it's a
card based fantasy rpg with 3d realistic
graphics i mean the graphics look insane
but this game has a ridiculously unique
feat so check this out one of the things
that you can do is while you can bring
different companions it can be your
companion and so on and so forth you can
also produce heirs so you can choose
your own race and then you can choose a
companion of a different race and then
you can merge your bloodlines and what
you'll do is you'll basically produce an
air and that air will be a combination
of both of your bloodlines now it's not
arbitrary the nature in which your air
functions is a direct result of how you
raise it and what bloodlines you've
merged to create that air but your air
can in turn go on and marry heroes on
its own and then produce different
bloodlines based on that right so
literally it just kind of gets passed on
and passed on it's really cool you get
to like create your own evolution of
errors and there's no limit to what you
guys can do this feature alone was
enough for me to get into it i was like
okay i want to see how far this
stretches so having said that make sure
you guys check the link in the
description or you can scan the qr code
that's showing on screen right now and
you can use my gift code in the
description to get in-game rewards
you'll get one champion token and then
100 diamonds which is really really cool
so make sure you guys check that out and
let's get back into our video
so with zom having been locked away by
eternity right off the bat if zom is a
big enough threat that eternity thought
he needed to be locked away forever we
know we're dealing with an incredibly
powerful guy a notion that the ancient
one confirms when he states that
although zom is the only entity that can
defeat umar the cure may end up being
worse than the sickness if zom is
released nevertheless strange decides
that he has no choice but to liberate
zom which he does and as he breaks forth
from his prison zom exclaims let the
world within and the worlds without
tremble in their orbits zom lives again
so immediately we know that zom's ready
to just start screwing stuff up
immediately after being freed and he
even says that he plans to shatter world
after world with ease now predictably
zomb tries to kill doctor strange but
strange basically runs away and leaves
zomb right to umar who proclaims that
his power dwarfs her own and we also
learned that in order for eternity to
imprison zom zom first had to be bound
by dormammu so it took the collective
effort of two beyond omega level
characters to imprison this guy so umar
tries to fight zom for like a few
seconds and then she just pieces out i
mean she literally says this is useless
i'm just gonna vanish and then
disappears so this villain who's more
powerful than dormammu just runs away
instead of fighting zom but with the
threat of umar neutralized zam decides
that he must have a victim so he sets
his sights on doctor strange and the
ancient one and after slaying them he
vows to destroy all mankind before
moving on to destroy other worlds now as
soon as the battle begins the ancient
one realizes the only move he has is to
sacrifice himself and transfer all his
power to doctor strange before he dies
however he tells dr strange that the
secret to defeating zomb is the forelock
and this is where things go off the
rails so after being momentarily
confused as to what his master was
talking about strange deduces that the
forelock refers to the strands of hair
on the front of zom's head basically his
bangs so strange flies up to zom and
uses his amulet to slice off zom's bangs
or azan calls it his mystic top knot now
even with the four lock severed strange
is no match for zom but the reason
removing it was key to victory is that
the removal of the four locks summoned
the living tribunal and this was the
first time we'd ever seen the tribunal
and if you're not familiar with him i
have done a video on him already that
you can basically check out but
essentially he's the most powerful
entity in marvel comics except for the
one above all and anybody else that
marvel just arbitrarily decides is more
powerful the beyonders the molecule man
owen reese the fedex guys who actually
deliver packages on time for a change
but the living tribunal's purpose is to
maintain balance in the universe and he
sees zom and decides that he must be
returned to his prison and then declares
that doctor strange must face the
tribunal's judgment for unleashing a
force that threatens the worlds beyond
so the next time we see zom is on
another occasion many years later when
once again doctor strange believes
releasing him is the only way to save
the world now this was during the events
of world war hulk which saw the hulk
return to earth after being sent to
another planet against his will falling
in love getting married only to see his
wife killed when the spaceship that took
him there explodes so he comes back to
earth pissed off as he's ever been to
get revenge on the ones who sent him
away one of which is doctor strange of
course this group being the illuminati
now after strange tries to reason with
the hulk the hulk breaks his hands and
once again leaves dr strange desperate
for a solution to a global threat now
it's worth pointing out this version of
hulk typically called world breaker hulk
is arguably the most powerful version of
the hulk that we've ever seen with the
exception of the heart of the monster
hulk and definitely was the most
powerful that he'd ever been up to that
point but regardless strange once again
decides to release the power of zom but
this time he breaks the contents of the
amphora imbuing himself with zom's power
then we get an epic battle between
doctor strange being amped by zom's
abilities and the hulk and at first
strange is wiping the floor with this
guy however when strange has a crisis of
conscience that he put regular people in
danger hulk capitalizes on this
distraction and then beats him to a pulp
but the fact that merely the essence of
zom was able to overpower this version
of the hulk is in and of itself a
testament to zom's insane power
especially when we realize that this is
only a fraction of zom's original power
but after strange is defeated zom's
essence leaves him and searches for a
new host first settling on the
hulkbuster armor which was equipped with
an anti-matter device that could destroy
basically the entire world eventually a
weakened zom possesses amadeus cho and
is imprisoned once again when cho is
knocked unconscious but zom would
resurface again during the events of
chaos war which saw the chaos king kill
nightmare and banish death herself from
the universe but during the course of
this conflict it's revealed that there
was apparently a part of zom's essence
that remained with doctor strange and
the chaos king frees it and allows zom
to once again possess steven now zom is
able to quickly dispatch the hulk and
sets off in search of a woman named
marlo chandler the ex-wife of rick jones
whose body contained a piece of death
within it but when zom finds marlow she
releases death which seemingly kills
zomk and then after that we haven't
really seen or heard from him since but
he definitely belongs in the beyond
omega level category as a mystical demon
that seems to be comparable to some of
the cosmic entities in terms of power
but let me know what you guys think
right do you guys think zom is an
interesting villain you guys want to see
him in the mcu and make sure you guys
give me some ideas for some videos thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace